our men of talent and Men of preparation
for her to be the latter I put five
times the amount of work in this book as
I did compared to offers I think offers
is exceptional I think this book is
better
I have half a million people we'll have
more than the city of Baltimore you can
look in a skyscraper look all the way
around Baltimore and be like more than
everyone I can see with my eyes is
registered for this event when you have
that many people like there's a lot of
things that can go wrong I mean most
people spend their entire lives not
being able to like influence 500 000
people there's a 17 year old who's going
to sleep with this book under his pillow
to get out of his situation you owe it
to him is he gonna sell something right
now
gonna be a run twists and turns on this
roller coaster
you ready completely so worried she's
like wait you changed something it's
like oh yeah honestly the whole goal was
that everything worked that's all we
want little did I know that as soon as I
stepped on stage uh like three massive
tissues break behind the scenes based on
the sheer volume of clicks that were
going at the same time
you gotta touch the bottom of the bull
that's what makes it memorable